wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
i miei colleghi hanno parlato di un
countdown sulla componente ambientale ma
stiamo vivendo un countdown anche sulla
componente sociale la risposta avrei
darvi cercare di darvi una risposta ad
una domanda ci sono capitali privati
derivanti da banche piuttosto che da
fondi di investimento che possono
aiutare lo stato italiano dalle risposte
ai bisogni propri cittadini
vediamolo assieme per vedere questa cosa
vorrei partire dal concetto di stato con
la prima caratteristica di uno stato
quello di avere un territorio che è
delimitato da dei confini
all'interno di questo territorio ci sono
una popolazione che condivide una lingua
degli usi dei costumi
questa popolazione sede parte della
propria sovranità a chi al governo il
governo può essere un sistema centrale
regionale o locale
cosa fa il governo
per noi si eroga dei servizi che possono
essere dei servizi assistenziali
sanitari piuttosto che dei servizi
informativi dalle scuole materne fino
all'università dei servizi sulla
componente della pubblica sicurezza
tribunali polizia dei servizi di ricerca
per lo sviluppo del mercato
in cambio di questi e tanti altri
servizi
il governo o i diversi livelli di
governo che cosa fanno chiedono una
quota parte della ricchezza che ognuno
di noi produce attraverso il lavoro all
imprenditoria la tassazione
oggi quello che voglio fare è dirvi dove
vanno a finire le nostre tasse e
soprattutto in tema di sistema socio
sanitario
convoco fitto virtualmente qui a fianco
a me la signora maria che potrebbe
essere vostra zia mia madre mia nonna
purtroppo la signora maria a un
incidente domestico e si rompe un femore
la signora maria deve finire in ospedale
avere un intervento chirurgico e poi
incominciare una degenza che può
arrivare fino alla durata di 30 giorni
alla fine tutto questo calvario la
signora maria può finalmente ritornare a
casa
chi paga per tutte le spese sostenute
dalla signora maria oggi pagano i
contribuenti tutti noi c'è un modello
alternativo a questo dove anche il
privato possa contribuire ai pagamenti
delle spese per le cure della signora
maria
il motivo per cui sono qui oggi è
proprio dirvi se c'è o meno c'è si
chiama payment by result pagamento a
fronte di risultati quali sono le sue
caratteristiche si basa su una
partnership pubblico privata utilizza
invece che risorse pubbliche risorse
private per lanciare scalare modelli di
business sociale innovativi che capaci
di dare risposta ai crescenti bisogni
sociali
vediamo allora col modello del paine
barisal come cambia la situazione della
signora maria alla signora maria
purtroppo cambia poco il femore rompe
comunque finisce in ospedale
a l'evento chirurgico rimane in
osservazione per 12 giorni quelli
classici post evento chirurgico qui
cambia il modello nel senso che entra in
gioco enrico chi è ricco adesso voi vi
chiederete è un imprenditore sociale del
territorio di riferimento
che cosa ha fatto enrico ha identificato
un modello di business sociale prendendo
degli appartamenti sfitti dotandoli del
personale e delle strumentazioni
necessarie per curare maria come tutti
gli imprenditori in italia enrico ha
bisogno di risorse finanziarie killer a
laura laura chi è era dirigente di una
banca italiana
realmente esistente che ha una divisione
orientata all impatto sociale e che
firma con questi attori dei contratti di
debito o credito a seconda del punto di
vista in cui c'è scritto dentro
carissimo enrico più tu sarei bravo a
raggiungere gli obiettivi d'impatto che
fa la tua impresa meno interesse dovrai
corrispondermi sul debito che io ti ho
concesso benissimo adesso tutto dovresti
dire dovreste dirmi sì ma nicola ma il
pubblico che fine ha fatto dove è finito
il pubblico si è accorto che riccò è
molto bravo e che opera all'interno del
contesto di riferimento è infatti zanni
che l assessore alle politiche sociali
di questo territorio e che sempre a
delle deficienze in termini di budget
così come tutti i suoi colleghi perché
ha delle deficienze in termini di budget
piccolo calcolo ogni persona che se
compri un femore in italia più o meno
costa operazione inclusa a 400 euro al
giorno per una media di 20 giorni
decenza su tutto l'ospedale sullo
stivale scusate
equivale a 8.000 euro per singolo caso
media di 500 casi per una provincia
medio piccola italiana totale 4 milioni
di euro di costo il 5 per cento del
totale dei costi di una media provincia
italiana quindi capite che per gianni
questo è un grave problema zanni a
questo punto
sottoscrive un accordo con enrico però
lo sottoscrive secondo le regole del pe
member esalta cioè all'interno di questo
contratto vengono elencate una serie di
risultati che riccò deve riuscire a
dimostrare di raggiungere per poter
vedere sbloccate le risorse economiche
nei suoi confronti che è il soggetto che
a questo punto valida e valuta se ricco
è stato così bravo da raggiungere questi
risultati il soggetto valutatore che
attraverso una raccolta di rimandi dati
qualitativi
o quantitativi redige un report definito
report d'impatto cosa c'è dentro questo
report impatto si evidenzia quanto
enrico col suo modello sia stato capace
di dare risposte ai problemi della
signora maria quanto qualitativamente
sia stato buono il suo servizio e quanto
dall'altro punto di vista la signora
maria e tutti i suoi familiari siano
contenti del servizio erogato
se la risposta a queste tre e molti
altri criteri è positiva allora gianni è
contento perché la signora maria ha
ricevuto un ottimo servizio dall'altra
parte ha generato un risparmio di spesa
perché lui ha pagato solo per
l'operazione
e i primi due giorni di post degenza gli
altri diciotto giorni li ha pagati
enrico una quota parte di questi
risparmi vengono quindi rigirati ad
enrico che può pagare i propri fattori
produttivi
il personale piuttosto che gli affitti
dei propri appartamenti e dall'altra
parte rifondere il debito a laura che
sarà un altro attore che sarà
doppiamente contento perché vede
ritornare il proprio finanziamento e
dall'altra parte anche generato impatto
sociale positivo nel territorio di
riferimento
ricapitolando quali sono gli attori del
sistema del pm barese alt una pubblica
amministrazione
permettetemi di aggiungere lungimirante
che definisce sempre gli obiettivi che
devono essere raggiunti un sistema di
imprese sociali territoriali
innovative capaci quindi di avere dei
modelli capaci di dare risposta ai nuovi
bisogni sociali
dall'altra parte degli enti finanziatori
qui non stiamo parlando di firenze di
filantropia quindi banche piuttosto che
fondi di investimento che vogliono porre
e proprio capitale di rischio avendo dei
ritorni finanziari ma anche avendo
ritorno in termini di impatto e poi
infine il soggetto valutatore che è il
collante di tutto il modello per l'enpa
result questo non è un modello bello
solo in teoria a livello mondiale sono
circa 60 70 i progetti attivi
attualmente che utilizzano questo
modello e le utilizzano sull'ambito
della formazione per ridurre il drop out
scolastico nell'ambito delle carceri
ridurre la recidiva
nell'ambito degli anziani supportare
quindi l'invecchiamento attivo
nell'ambito della riduzione degli
effetti negativi dei cambiamenti
climatici e nell'ambito
dell'identificazione di nuovi modelli
per dare risposte alle nuove povertà
pensate adesso che siamo anche di fronte
all'arrivo delle risorse di next gen new
hope inr r se in cominciassimo a usare
queste risorse
pagando coloro che offrono i servizi per
il pubblico non tanto in termini di
quantità
quindi il numero di persone formate il
numero di persone accolte il numero di
persone accudite ma in termini di
qualità quanto sei stato bravo quanto
hai fatto del bene a quella persona
buona immaginazione a tutti
[Musica]
[Applauso]